welcome back to another edition of
gadget lab show I'm Michael colori
Nathan only wadis Giles later on we're
going to see a new version of
Microsoft's outlook.com web-based email
which is super exciting but first we
have some phones from huawei and
t-mobile yes we do we have the mytouch
and the mytouch q which are two brand
new handsets out on t-mobile they're
built by Huawei specifically for tmobile
but if you look I'll tell tell us
there's no Huawei branding here going on
you know tell us a little bit about
Huawei like people may not be familiar
why Wayne up is more than likely a
company you know you've never heard of
but they are a Chinese smartphone and
tablet manufacturer trying to enter the
US market they've worked with tmobile to
build a tab that was called the t-mobile
springboard yeah which is actually
pretty solid pretty solid device
pre-salt tablet but they're really just
doing like bargain basement stuff right
now a really low cost of their there
they're trying so which is reflected in
this in these two devices that we have
here as a matter of fact it is so these
two phones are part of t-mobile's might
touch line which is essentially a
low-cost phone that is designed for
people who have never had a smartphone
before we've never had an android phone
before that kind of thing so one of
these like 50 bucks on contract 100
bucks nun komm these are a hundred bucks
on contracts but there's a fifty-dollar
mail-in rebate oh that drops the price
and a half okay if you you know so
what's the catch the catch well here
it's that the hardware is outdated in
the software outdated that's the problem
which is probably why they're 50 bucks
it's kind of a shame because in the past
t-mobile's mytouch line was really
actually pretty good maybe about a year
ago they came out with the mytouch 4g
slide which was built by HTC and it had
one of the nicest smartphone cameras out
there is really great piece of hardware
then they went with LG and released to
other phones that were also called the
mytouch of mytouch q and now they're
with huawei and i gotta say i'm frankly
kind of disappointed by
what they're presenting here yeah so we
should mention that this one this is the
cute right yeah this is the cute as a
slide-out keyboard q is for QWERTY I
guess maybe like maybe could be I mean
it's kind of nice to see that they're
offering a keyboard that's not something
you see on smartphones a lot nowadays
yeah it's just weird yeah and I thought
almost hey uncomfortable if maybe you're
used to this if you've had a blackberry
and you want to get a smartphone that
can actually run some apps and and and
do a lot more things than BlackBerry's
can do then this might be kind of like a
peace offering to you but you know yeah
that's the difference here they're the
exact same phones the queue has the
keyboard the regular mytouch sans q no
keyboard and I understand why they're
still making devices with keyboards
because it you know with the two-year
cycle of bones like two years ago there
are a lot more phones that had physical
keyboards in there aren't this is true
this is true so people may not quite be
ready to give it up but yeah come on
just give it up yeah the beef that I
have with the mytouch in mytouch q is
that you're going to have to live with
these soul in the next two years if you
sign it to your contract and you get it
for 50 bucks it's an enticing price but
the thing is that these phones already
feel maybe a year or two behind the
times um the problem is here you have
your running Gingerbread which is two
generations old for android now yeah and
then you know you have like a 1.4
gigahertz single core processor that's a
little behind the time it's gonna feel
really bad in about six months you only
have four gigabytes of include storage
although there's a microSD card slot so
if you want to expand you can and then
you know you have one gigabyte of RAM
which is pretty robust and that is up to
today's smartphone standards so good
enough but you'll certainly be hurting
in a year and you could do a lot better
for 100 bucks right now well yeah for
100 bucks right now you can get the
Galaxy Nexus from verizon you can get
the atrix HD from eighteen t 4 150 bucks
you can get the HTC One S from t-mobile
so there's lots of other handsets out
there kind of in the same price range
that offer you a far better device
that's going to feel a lot better in two
years but you know if you're a
cheapskate or if you really only want to
spend fifty dollars in your phone this
is this is pretty solid I've been
playing around with the fruit yeah it's
a good little phone you know it's good
good build quality I wish it didn't feel
so outdated but
a good phone all right well thanks for
stopping by and bringing your huawei
devices my pleasure and as we send you
on your way way we'll bring in alexander
to show us something for Microsoft
hi Alexandra hi Mike uh so you got a
sneak peek at outlook.com is that
correct that is correct and it's
actually live now though okay so that's
out but outlook calm is basically
Microsoft's new webmail service mmm um
they had hotmail which was pretty lame
yeah a cornerstone of the early web yeah
but now past its prime mm-hmm but now
they've come out with outlook calm and
it's basically their their answer to
webmail gmail came out like eight years
ago and they've according to them that's
like it's been too long since webmail
has gone to redesign and this is what
they've come up with so this is this is
sort of is this like their attempt to
compete with Gmail or one up Gmail i'm
pretty sure it's 21 up gmail yeah and
they've done a pretty good job okay so
what are the one of the hot features I
mean does it have your prison bolts and
everything the gmail has it has
revolution yes because everything gmail
has but a totally different look what
about Chad yep chat so it features
facebook skype and then i'm gonna say
messenger which I don't use but people
in other countries do yeah I'm sure
people yeah so you can chat through all
of those services that's club but you
can't tap into google talk which can be
a drawback for some people i see i mean
if you are a gmail user now it's hard to
think of a reason why you would want to
switch to outlook outlook but i think
people are interested just because like
a million people signed up right index
hours it also seems like it's tied
really closely into microsoft's other
online services like it was talking and
sharing if people want to send you
photos it's used it operates with the
SkyDrive is that right right and one
cool thing so you can open word docs
excel spreadsheets and powerpoints like
in the actual webmail browser and then
if people send you photos it'll like you
can play the photos in a slideshow like
format that overlays outlook that's very
cool but only if you have Silverlight
right yeah yeah something
missing out on silverlight but i mean
there's still plenty of features in here
you know that so if you can live without
the you know the animated flickr
slideshow you're probably yeah it's
super clean looking that's one thing I'm
really like it has that whole metro
design very flat boxy no unnecessary
lines which you can see there and it's
designed to work natively on
touchscreens and on tablets right which
i think is pretty important considering
that we're either going to be seeing
tablets or touchscreen computers when
Windows 8 comes out yeah I mean they've
they've made some sort of like custom
features for touchscreens it's it's
still easier to use with the mouse but
it's definitely usable on this tablet at
least that's very cool so since it's a
web app it's easy for them to make
updates and push them out whenever so we
expect to see a lot more features in the
future right one other thing that we
should mention before we leave is that
we just had a redesign on gadget lab so
if you go to wire calm / gadget lab if
you're not there right now you'll see
that the whole page has been redesigned
there's big stories and big art at the
top and there is little sort of
aggregation posts on the side click
around let us know what you think leave
a comment we are always eager to hear
your feedback about what we're doing on
wired also we should mention that
Christine is not with us this week
because she's down covering the trial
between Apple and Samsung and their
never-ending long ongoing the patent
disputes so she'll be back next week on
the show to give us a wrap up of all the
news coming out of that trial until then
see you next week